tembec onze mille exemplaires sont là
pour satisfaire chaque lecteur christine
sauvage la libraire gérante nous partage
son coup de coeur le dernier livre de
marc dugain se projette dans l'avenir en
2060 ou un peu plus et il décrit une
entreprise dont la directrice est une
femme qui a développé une intelligence
artificielle au point de créer son
propre personnage pour démontrer que ce
personnage est réel et bien son double
elle va se suicider et c'est son
personnage qui va continuer à gérer et à
faire une opé a surtout les grands
financiers du monde entier qu'il nous
dit quelque chose de notre présent et
notre avenir
cette libraire sort de ses livres et
voyage beaucoup elle a parcouru les
andes
je connais bien l'amérique latine j'ai
parcouru les andes du sud au nord
presque jusqu'aux normalement qu'un
petit bout des andes en colombie
je connais bien c'est civilisation
aztèque inca istres que laurent binet
renverse l'histoire est à dire qu à 1
492 christophe colomb n'a pas découvert
l'amérique ce sont les incas qui
envahissent l'europe est clivant imposer
leur civilisation
christine sauvage et passionné et
continuera de transmettre le goût de la
littérature même à la retraite qu'elle
prendra le 31 janvier